I want to hit every goal like I don't
like missing goals for me I don't like
teaching myself or teaching other people
that if I say something's going to
happen it doesn't happen like I think
you absolutely should think really big
but then like okay how do I make a goal
and then once I have that goal do the
activities that make it unreasonable not
to hit it if you're like I want to learn
sales I would say it's unreasonable that
if you get on 10 000 sales calls you
will not be good at sales the
unreasonable couple years you could do
it okay that's a goal and I can set that
and if I do the activities it would be
unreasonable that I'm not now
realistically you probably get there in
half the time because you're probably
pretty good at sales even if your first
two three thousand calls